Why don't you give me the first word that comes to mind when you think of each other?
bitch.
Well, at least we're on same page. That's good
All right, let's try this: name one thing you both like about each other
He doesn't snore. She's good at taxes.
Aah... Looking for something a bit more personal
He doesn't like the Gilmore Girls. I think that's a pretty likable thing.
Alright well let's to talk about your son. He's...
Five.
Seven
He's actually six according to the file. I was gonna ask you about his behavior, but
You know what let's change gears; how often you both have sex?
masturbation counts right?
Uhhh. I mean not really no.
I'd say a couple times a week.
Do the weekends counts?
All right, we're out of time
Let's pick up again next week. In the meantime I want you both to give each other three compliments before our next session
That's easy, right?
Is that a trick question?
Yeah, I don't understand the question
Are you excited for the park?
Make some friends man. Have fun!
He doesn't have kids my friends because you what are you talking what I'm talking about to you?
How you acting if he's cute?
What are you saying look I?
Work hard punching numbers while you get stoned and get lost in the beyond section of your stupid store
Okay, first of all who cares about the stone. I'm doing inventory. You'd want to be stoned
- all right you're just an over glorified accountant
Can I play with you guys? You think you can play with us shrimp? Get out of here. Hey mom!
Have fun honey! Yeah, have fun
I pay the bills and maybe you would notice that if you're spending all your after-hours at your creepy friend chick's
Chick is my manager.
Yeah, I'm a manager
Yeah, of Bed bath and Beyond
No f***ing way,
Hey, loser!
What the f***?
Honey?
What what is he doing playing with it?
It's Spongebob.
Have you ever seen the cartoon Spongebob yeah?
Yeah, he's a sponge.
This is way too violent.
toys like this, it's just
Hey, could you do these kids?
Look alive pretty fresh all your fault. Maybe amazing shut up
Let's go
Can you snap that kids femur?
Good job Michael. Yeah
Well you both look good. Oh yeah, we worked it out and we're opening up our own business
Well, that's great together. No. I'm opening my own tea shop. Oh
Coffee shop. Well he's healthier, and I won't be riddled with hipsters
g is for pussies, and we won't be riddled with those I
Mean unless Mr.. Lipton decides to stop by and see his wife
These two could operate together in cats, right?
All good, okay. Let's talk about oh, I got a hand job in the car
that's getting somewhere and
Michael where is he right? He's in school
It's 16
Yeah
Jesus Christ, I've never met two bigger Moronic dipshit assholes in my life
Who am I to judge sorry was not?
great Grand Wonderful sentiment